I think the wider question and the
debate this has triggered this whole
story has triggered this week is about
how should we understand China because
some of the reaction to this story has
been that anyone who calls for more
sophisticated approach to China as this
alleged spy did do is seen with an
ulterior motive but I think that's wrong
because in an open Society we should
look at the merits of an argument on
their own regardless of who's saying it
now obviously it's different if someone
is being paid by a foreign state or
coerced by Foreign state to do something
like that but that doesn't mean that the
arguments that they're raising or the
arguments are similar people similar to
them are raising are not worth listening
to and you know for me this is quite a
personal question Freddie as you know
because Chinese Whispers my podcast
tries to do this we try to make our
understanding of China more complex more
sophisticated it's a big country with a
long history